a couple years ago I was you know living
my life and they said hey do you want to
come perform at this function and I
think it was like a couple thousand
bucks they said you want to come perform
at this function might have been $1,500
and just come in the back and we you
know we'll meet you back there and come
in and you'll be going the stage you're
gonna perform for a little while and
then Suzanne Somers gonna do it
and Suzanne Somers this lady I mean she
really she looks like she has a real
strong kind of butthole on her to be
honest and I know honest I've never said
that about anyone actually but it looks
like her you know her little bee hole
could probably I bet it could I bet it
could probably blow a bubble with some
gum if it had to gum in it so that's
what I'm kind of saying look like she
just has a really she's real strong she
always does leg fitness and um glute fit
and you know glute Fitness and glute is
just so you don't say but that's all
glue it is but so I was there I go in
the back I go onstage I perform it's a
little bizarre it's like all these
people sitting in there you know one
dude has on like a top hat people are
like screaming you know and fired up and
and there's like a clock that's counting
down on the wall like you know I don't
remember where it's at like 40 minutes
or something so then I get done
performing I go back backstage I haven't
even been to the front of the event so
they say look man if you want to go
around front get you a little chocolate
cake because they were doing dinner when
I was on stage and they had just gotten
into the dessert portion of the evening
I not be honest I love a dessert all
right you know I'm sick of people acting
like we just like dinner bitching I like
it all okay I want dessert I want that I
want lime slices I want it all [ __ ]
okay that's who I am I'm sick of sitting
at the menu every time we get the menu
have to look at all the other stuff
first but give me a menu that just has
dessert on it and I'll be fine okay I'll
have nine scoops ice cream that's fine
brah actually I wish they'd served
everything in ice cream salad ice cream
steak ice cream pork chop ice cream dude
I would have it one amount of mmm oh so
I go around front I go in then I'm out
so now I'm able to see the stage from
the front and see what everybody else is
saying there's like this countdown clock
of like when the new product is gonna
launch there's like all of these um it
was cold like yeah it was like a vitamin
thing like power vy or something or some
i don't know what it was dude and they
had these patches you put on your head
and helps you sleep and stuff and when
you put under your neck or whatever and
it keeps ants off your body they had
they had one pie they had like these
other yeah this patches you put them on
your shoulder and you put you know
you'll never think about your
ex-girlfriend or something or you know
they got these patches you it's like um
you put them on the backi legs and you
can drive better just all kind of
[ __ ] but everybody was in there and
they were fired up and the new patches
were about to launch and and i was like
holy [ __ ] mount is performed at a
pyramid scheme I didn't realize I was
like damn I just performed at a pyramid
scheme and I look on stage and Susanna
Sam was up there with that strong ass
freaking bang you know that back jaw she
got that real hearty back jaw and uh and
she was talking about something
magnesium I think or something I don't
know but but yeah we all get caught up
we all get caught up evening good
afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes your life well
you could watch this one or
watch this one watch this one watch this
one watches one